I'm showing you the rig that has been
set up I don't if you can see but it's
really massive we're here in front of
Holyrood Palace and this is all ready
for the broadcaster's to come in here
and report on the referendum there's a
real tense air in edinburgh and i'm sure
all across scotland as i was just
talking about people are really nervous
about which way it might go families
divided on how they're going to vote
either way almost half the population is
going to be really upset on Friday I've
heard they're going to be parties during
the day other people not so happy I'm
sure there'll be a police presence
wherever we go one of the things that
Alex Salmond has done really
successfully is to switch people from no
to yes votes I met someone who said that
they were a staunch no but now they're
definitely definitely going to vote yes
they don't like the scare mongering of
the No campaign and they find the idea
of n Miliband David Cameron Nick Clegg
here in the final few weeks a little bit
cringe-worthy others passionately for no
they think it could be an economic
disaster to vote yes they're very very
nervous about the pole and they'll be
just hoping that this slight Poli
they've still got will push them through
to friday morning